[Applause]
thank you
how am I wired
how does my brain work
why am I good at some things
why are other things more difficult for
me
these are questions that I've spent
countless hours reflecting upon and
trying to answer
as humans we are naturally curious
creatures
and it is very human to want to
understand ourselves
we are shaped by our experiences
in the way that our brains process
information function and learn impacts
these experiences and how we view these
experiences
all these facets also influence our
personality and how we both present and
view ourselves
when we work against ourselves and we
don't play to our strengths it can feel
like we're using the wrong wiring
things just aren't working
tasks are more difficult in thinking
feels uncomfortable
our internal dialogue begins to feel
more strained
be careful how you talk to yourself
because you are listening
the way that we talk to ourselves
impacts our relationship with ourselves
and we talk to ourselves more than
anyone else
but when we accept our brain and we play
to our strengths our internal dialogue
feels like we're talking to a friend
for me having ADHD in a sensory
processing disorder impacts how my brain
processes information functions and
learns
it impacts how I view the world and how
I express myself
I love Creative Endeavors and I'm
learning to love organization
my brain usually feels like a pile of
colorful wires or organized chaos
everything makes me think of everything
and I love that about myself
but it also makes things like learning
in a classroom or focusing when there's
a lot of external stimuli pretty
difficult
when I accepted my brain myself for who
I am
it felt like the start of a beautiful
friendship
I accept you
I understand you
let's be friends
in the start of this friendship prompted
me to ask
how can we be happier together
and I'll ask you all the same
one is your brain happy
I'll invite you to close your eyes but
you can also keep them open
when your brain is happy
what are you doing
how does it feel
do multiple things come to mind
or only a select few
do you do these things often
or only every once in a while
if you close your eyes you can open them
now
I find that my brain is happiest when I
can experience these three modes of
thinking throughout the day
dreaming
focused thinking and not thinking
dreaming is my default mode of thinking
I'm a heavy Daydreamer and I have been
since I was a child
my parents dubbed this far away place
that I go
the Autumn verse
I love imagining new experiments art
projects and futures for myself
and although I can move into this mode
of thinking at virtually any time
I especially like to dream while I'm
running
I imagine myself chasing my goals and
overcoming challenges
allowing ourselves to dream is a lot of
fun
not taking ourselves too seriously
and taking the pressure off
create space for creativity and problem
solving
I've actually solved countless homework
problems while running
while I'm at work I'm in Focus thinking
mode
for me it's a very specific feeling of
being locked in
I feel this when I'm running experiments
processing data writing papers
in Reading reports
I like to get locked into this mode with
music
making a fun work playlist motivates me
to sit down and get to work lately I've
been listening to a lot of Beyonce but I
really like all music
and finally
not thinking
to me not thinking is being present
and giving my focused thinking mind a
break
activities that help me experience this
mode of thinking
our yoga cooking and drawing or painting
it is a time to just be
and it helps me to recharge my focus
I try to commit to one mode of thinking
at a time
and avoid being stuck in between two
modes
for instance
if you need a break from work
but you are so determined to keep on
working even after your focus is long
gone
you can end up feeling frustrated that a
simple task has now taken two to three
times longer than normal
I think we've all been there
be a friend to your brain get into a new
mode of thinking
shift gears
I arrived at these three modes of
thinking through a lot of intentional
self-reflection
I reflected on things that I'm good at
and things that I find difficult
and being really honest with myself
about it
I thought about things that I've loved
since childhood and who I am at my core
maybe you also like to experience these
three modes of thinking
maybe they look a little bit different
for you
what activities came to mind in each of
these categories
how can you find balance among these
activities throughout your day
through this reflection I've realized
that I'm happiest when I'm creating
art was my first love as a child and I
consider myself first and foremost an
artist
in the laboratory water implants are my
artistic mediums
in the studio markers paints and
photographs are my artistic mediums
surrealism art allows me to blend My Two
Worlds Without boundaries
being best friends with my brain means
not holding myself back
in letting myself jump in the kitchen
and dream that I'm reaching for the Moon
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]